[Music]
last night at the Golden Globes Alfonso
Cuaron won Best Director for gravity now
our English is not Alfonso's first
language add to that the pressure of
being on live national television and
well Alphonso may have said a few things
he didn't mean to say well thank you the
Hollywood Foreign Press Santa you are
the most amazing collaborator generosity
your commitment I'm going to give you
herpes pronounced my son and co-writer
I'm going to give you herpes I'm going
to give you herpes
thank you Steve Robbie no herpes
Henrique Holmes herpes Gary Snyder
herpes Marcus and Tracy Schneider herpes
herpes muchas muchas gracias mi mama I'm
going to give you herpes
[Applause]
[Music]